foreign
federal agents destroying equipment used
by legal miners in Brazil's largest
indigenous Reserve it's part of an
emergency operation launched by the
government in January to save the
Yanomami people from Extinction
but they aren't the only ones in danger
mining in the Amazon has exploded in
recent years affecting not only the
Yanomami but also the kaipo and muduruku
people the government is now addressing
the problem by chasing away the illegal
miners but it's not enough that's why
our tribal leaders have formed an
alliance to take off fight against
Invaders to a new level
traveled all the way to Asia to meet
representatives of the South Korean
company Hyundai
to convince them to stop selling
excavators to retailers in the Amazon
these machines are being used to kill
our rivers and our people
foreign
these aerial images taken by Greenpeace
show the devastation produced by legal
mining in indigenous territories
during the last government led by Jai
bolsonaro 390 square kilometers of the
Amazon were destroyed by miners that's
twice the amount of the area destroyed
during the four previous years
deforestation is only part of the
problem mercury used by miners has
polluted the rivers causing a Health
crisis among the indigenous people they
were left with no water to drink nor
fish to eat
as soon as he took office in January
president whizinasu Lula da Silva took
action he expelled around 20 000 illegal
miners from the Yanomami Reserve but
machines used in mining are also a big
part of the problem
Greenpeace identified
176 excavators being used in the area
almost half of them were from Hyundai
oh wow
Hyundai representatives in South Korea
were surprised when they heard our
report but they also showed interest in
cooperating with the Brazilian
government to make sure their machines
would no longer be used for illegal
activities during bolsonaro's government
indigenous leaders felt they were alone
defending the world's largest rainforest
now they say they have hope things will
change
Al Jazeera Brasilia
33 soldiers have been killed